taking away from workers an important
bargaining chip namely the ability to
offer to work a wage less than the
minimum is the cruelest thing you can do
for a lot of these workers in a short
period the $15 minimum wage went from
laughable to viable as a New York Times
headline put it and now it's the law of
the land for millions of New Yorkers and
Californians earlier this month the
Empire and Golden State's almost
simultaneously passed laws that will
boost the state mandated wage for 215
dollars over the next few years it's a
high-stakes bet that the law of supply
and demand does not apply to human life
I'm joined by George Mason University
economist Don Boudreau who also blogs
that cafe hi Don thanks for joining us
happy to be here Nick okay so economic
theory teaches us that if you raise the
price of something everything else being
equal you get less of it so the $15
minimum wage will destroy jobs for the
least skilled members of the workforce
okay
that I had a no doubt yep but then
supporters of the minimum wage say hey
you know what markets aren't perfect and
that labor particularly in service
industries like fast food
car washes hotel cleaning it's an
imperfect market so there's some
slippage there many workers in
California New York earning 12 or 13 or
even 14 dollars an hour is it possible
for them this will just bump them up and
no some of them are going to lose their
jobs others of them the nature of the
job might change the employer might
become more strict and demand you know
more effort per hour so there are lots
of ways the employers can adjust but
employers are not going to stand back
and just absorb that higher wage it's
just not going to happen look as
imperfect as it is the unskilled labor
market is highly competitive a lot of
things unskilled workers can do there
are a lot of employers competing for
those skills workers can move they can
move physically they can move across the
street and because it's so competitive
and because the industries in which
these workers work are competitive
fast-food motels they're not a lot of
margins okay so they can't just say you
know if it ends up costing McDonald's an
extra 30% in costs to produce something
they can't just raise the price 30% the
prices will up somewhat but but look
when the prices of McDonald's hamburgers
go up people buy fewer McDonald's
hamburgers which means McDonald's needs
fewer workers no matter how you cut it
some workers are going to lose their
jobs talk a little bit you hear a lot in
this context about automation and
particularly about
places like fast-food restaurants how
does automation intersect with increased
labor costs one thing that capital can
do is substitute for workers and so when
the relative price of labor Rises
employers seeking to keep their profits
as high as possible
search for ways to replace those higher
cost workers one way is to put in
machines with the advance of technology
that's becoming easier and easier we've
all seen automatic checkout lanes at
supermarkets that's an example of the
kind of technology that can substitute
for low-skilled workers so does that
mean that a couple of years ago when
Obama's blamed declines in employment on
ATM machines he wasn't necessarily wrong
he was wrong in the sense that when
technology advances in some workers lose
their jobs they are not necessarily
excluded from the workforce forever if
they can find other employers who are
willing to employ them at a wage at
which they are profitable to employ
right the problem with the minimum wage
is it prevents employers from hiring any
workers underneath that stipulated
minimum and so it's the wage that prices
them out of the job not the technology
in 1994 economist Alan Krueger and David
Card published a very influential paper
on the effect of the minimum wage in the
fast-food industry on the border of New
Jersey and Pennsylvania and they said
that it should little negative impact on
jobs what does the empirical evidence
show because we've seen this in people
like Paul Krugman and others have said
you know what I used to be a minimum
wage fundamentalist now a lot of people
are saying no no that's totally wrong
well not a lot there are some economists
card and Krueger is still being the most
famous errand Roger Dube another there
are a handful of studies that find no
negative effect on jobs because of
higher minimum wages there are many many
other studies David Newmark and William
washer only the two most prominent
researchers findings there are many many
other sorts a majority of the studies
that find when you raise the minimum
wage you get fewer jobs for low-skilled
workers particularly as you expand the
time span of the study because it does
take some time for employees to adjust
and it's also worth pointing out that
the Krugerrand card study they were not
talking about doubling the minimum wage
in a few years they were talking about
relatively it was a relatively small the
$15 minimum wage in some cases is more
than doubling it does it matter that
it'll be phased in over three four five
six years were well it's an interesting
question because it's a bad policy it's
better that a bad policy be phased in
and
all at one at one time if the cynic and
I'm one I'm a political cynic I believe
one of the effects of this phasing in is
that will make it more difficult for
empirical researchers to actually detect
the negative employment effects because
there's a lot of stuff going on in the
economy at any point in time and some
researcher can say oh well yes there are
a few jobs but that's because of this
other thing not because of the minimum
wage so I mean this is kind of an
interesting conundrum for economics
right because the empirical evidence is
actually very difficult to gather I mean
do you but then if you only go with
theory you may be totally disconnected
from reality so what how do you square
that circle as somebody who is a free
marketer and participates in certain
kinds of Austrian economics which issues
empirical data but many we don't issue
it we recognize it has its value but but
we also understand the theory has value
you don't just cast out theory because
you have a few studies that happen to to
show some effects the vast majority of
studies on the minimum wage I'm
estimating 70% show a negative effect a
significant negative effect of higher
minimum wages of minimum wages on the
employment of low-skilled workers
usually proxy by teenagers so because
them if you have a startling claim such
as that the law of demand does not apply
to low-skilled workers it's a really
startling claim why wouldn't it apply to
that particular commodity rather than
smile then you really need startling
evidence to persuade me and I think
other sensible economist to reject the
claim that the law of demand applies to
those workers the evidence is nowhere
close to being dominant enough talk a
little bit about who earns the minimum
wage and under what circumstances
because you know it's something like 3%
of the overall labor market earns the
minimum wage are those people and where
do they show up 3.9 percent of all
American workers earn the minimum wage
or less about half of them or 25 years
younger than the age of 25 a full fifth
of them are still in their teens the
majority the single largest group of
minimum-wage workers have not even
completed high school so these are
unskilled workers most of them when they
get jobs because of the experience that
they get on the job they move to higher
paying jobs later one of the pernicious
effects of the minimum wage
you know is not only that it eliminates
the current income for the workers to
lose their jobs it eliminates something
more important it eliminates their
ability to get job experience and
on-the-job skills
talk about that because I mean if you
know this is one of the most potent
arguments and it's both an economic
argument but also a moral argument if
you do not allow people with low or no
skills to get that first job they can't
build up higher skills how do individual
workers raise their wages over time they
become more skilled and there are a
variety of different ways to do that
obviously formal education is one get an
accounting degree that increases your
skills for a lot of workers it's
actually working on the job learning how
to weld learning how to mow a lawn
learning how to show up on time and
learning how to cooperate with other
workers these are not things that are
natural to everyone and we forget those
of us who have had jobs we forget that
when we were younger these are things we
had to learn we don't come up out of the
womb with these talents and being on the
job consistently is one way to get those
skills I talk to people who run
businesses and hiring and finding good
employees reliable employees is very
valuable businesses don't regard work
good workers as expendable contrary to
what people like Bernie Sanders and a
lot of the progressive left think for
people who are you know and it's a small
percentage of minimum-wage workers who
are actually heading households it's as
you work yes you were talking about I
mean a lot of them actually make you
know they're not even at a high school
yet etc or we've seen from distribution
curves that there are as basically as
many minimum wage income earners in
high-income households as in poverty
level households so what do we do though
for those people who are trying to get
by on the minimum wage and they have a
family they have households what what
are alternative ways to help them get by
without costing them out of the economy
well the first thing I would say before
answering your question is even if there
was nothing to do the minimum wage is
still a bad idea because it's not it's
only gonna make the problem works even
if there are no other solutions but
there are some things we can do improve
schools increase school choice that will
make people more educated make people
more skilled get rid of occupational
licensing regulations that will open up
job opportunities
for lots of people so there are lots of
steps that government can take in my
view they pretty much all involve
getting the government out removing the
government from the economy to open up
the forces of competition and
entrepreneurship and innovation that
will open up opportunity it's taking
away from workers an important
bargaining chip namely the ability to
offer to work a wage less than the
minimum is the cruelest thing you can do
for a lot of these workers well we will
leave it there we have been talking to
Don Boudreau and economists at George
Mason University about the $15 minimum
wage that has been passed in California
New York Don thanks for talking to thank
you for raising TV I'm Nick Gillespie